buon salve a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questa entrata non fa più
oggi ha fatto un sacco di volte però lo
rifatta in hd perché sono nel mio nuovo
studio come hanno rifatto anche harry
stickman lo story giocando quindi li
facciamo entrate che ho già fatto taglia
tutto che un amen
perché dove iniziare vito così perché
perché dopo che le notizie siamo ragazzi
su friends and complex che è il
penultimo episodio per la ristic man
collection alla fine io finisco un po
come quando ero in schiavi razon nel
complesso mai complesso non è una
semplice prigione ma è la prigione dove
sono detenuti i più grandi menti
malvagie del mondo tra cui il nostro
buon harry per aver fatto tutte ste
cagate prima quindi le scuole
partiamo subito vediamo cosa succede non
mi ricordo niente vi ricordo solo la
trama in generale partiamo che mi hanno
già beccato come sempre benvenuto a the
wall
non è un album di michael jackson lei
chi cacchio è cosa hai fatto tu wait for
transfer playdead charge take robusta
playdead is grigorij isde beh ci ha
creduto subito tutta come lo buttiamo
nell'immondizia la cosa ma cosa vera è
una finestra nel muro l'immondizia è
stato e finisce sta roba
wait for transfer vi aspettiamo che si
trasferisca 20 grazie a te le porte sony
pulse oppure un bis con tutte le porte
centre for conte fisco le scelte le
porte della [ __ ] non era mai portato a
un cazzo però lo click ero sempre non
c'è verso
vabbè gigino re per genere andare perché
sarebbe questa la bellissima biscotto
che non sono dovrei tirato fuori dalla
cura non solo era meglio teleport per
laser
beh non vedo cosa ci sia di sbagliato
perfetto perfetto
oddio chiamo il governo chiamo il clan
di infiltrati 10 chiamo il governo
governo ok ciao è una merda sono in un
complesso è infatti la gli ha detto
esattamente questo perché questo non è
uno sbaglia questo scegliere una via un
altro che adesso sarebbe già rientrato
due finali
un'ora dopo aspettate sarà dato solo
nella mensa vabbè un casino ma sta
facendo questo flash news
il sito può mai grazie charles problema
è che c'è una cena guardia proprio come
ai vecchi tempi
charles questo sito scegliamo n'è
un'altra ragazza mini helicopter questo
bellissimo un mini drone un drone
elicottero perfetto e lui non a lui non
gliene fregava niente perché non
arpionato va bene sì però il problema
che c'è un sacco di gente
devo far fuori tutti uguali e che ne so
vado verso destra
dovevo far fuori quello con rocket
launcher effettivamente perché se no non
abbiamo ovviamente senso lo iacono rais
bravo charles grazie giuseppe
io glielo avrei puntato tutto
[Musica]
sono stato bravissimo pensavo molto
peggio invece ho finito neanche troppo
male con un miliardo di scelte
conosciuto a metà perché l'ho fatta
tutte queste giuste
uno su cinque ci sono cinque finali qua
prima demo avanti più finale ci sono
bellissima sta roba
va bè ragazzi li ho fatti tutti tranne
quando chiamò il top a clan
invece di chiamare il governo come piace
affatto viene da dentro la chiaro il
cambio di sto cacchio 10 un fenomeno
genio un'ora dopo aspettiamo sempre
un'ora prezzi quadro che ci mettono un
ora con tutto lei ci va bene se un po
eccessiva sta roba non se ne sono
accorti logici o nei cicli undercover
agent quindi sono uno di loro sotto
coperta stai zitto una volta in classe
durante la verifica un mio compagno mi
ha chiesto una soluzione e io glielo 6
miur lata perché nella mia mente c'era
che se io parlavo ad alta voce il
professore diceva aveva non sta dando le
soluzioni perché sennò non le direbbe ad
alta voce è un pirla che è quindi ho
usato questa tecnica di logica inversa
abbiamo preso due entrambi quindi grill
portano subito creduto usarlo anche
nella mia verifica
grazie ragazzi che tu dici sì ma ti
manca un dente non te ne sei accorto va
bene
magni mag matt alti attiro leggi lo
sapevo c'era neanche bisogno di sì che
ride con la moto va bene
questo caso monopattino poi che non ha
senso grazie che pezzo di me però non è
tanto quello quando mi aveva dato le
chip la prima volta poteva farlo subito
dopo che ho buttato giù un elicottero
potrà buttarmi giù che cacchio mai fatto
aspettare vent'anni per buttarvi che
sotto sentirla 2 di 5 sarà un finale
brutto qui un altro era un collegi
processo alla finale negativo va bene
sostenere i clic info la metal c'è
intendo che tu devi lavorarci per averla
perfetto bellissimo ma cosa succede e
cosa sta succedendo
ma cos'è sta roba no ho sbagliato sono
uscito per me lo meritavo male ragazzi
allora gli altri finali sono
dall'altra parte vi devo allora playdead
l'abbiamo fatto ma il fronte la sola via
4 change taylor 10 punti e quattro hanno
un buon finale
andiamo sua trombati be nice
com'è possibile perché sono un sacco di
scatole tua ci sarà solid snake nascosto
di dietro
item sì va be nice
chiaro riferimento a come schiavo per il
gioco famosissimo tetris e vado col
camion
ciao ragazzi e stato divertente ma anche
e mettermi sotto che si riportavano
fuori loro devo mi sa fare le cose
stretta credo bale non ho capito cosa ho
fatto ma fa niente è stato fighissimo me
lo facciamo con lo zoppo
ora che si è capito cosa o cliccato la
va bene
e andata malissimo ma male male male
male male forte ciao ragazzi devo
aspettare che gli faccia tutto il
discorso né poi schiaccia qualcosa alla
fine dei mr bang surrender surrender non
serve a niente
aspetto solo il tempo guarda scommetti
che lo sapevo
ciao e stato divertente presume dell
inverno fa un freddo cane va bene sono
un camion hanno caricato una cosa dove
son finito quel passaporto dove sto
andando
porca vacca cioè all'inizio questo il
mio modo di approcciare comunque uguale
quando io però la prigione aragon uguale
let's golf
devo aiutarla a scappare vieni vieni ko
se non è questa mi tradisce un po come
little nightmares synchronized the dawn
vengo 3 con perfetto penso che tra tutto
è ristic man collection fosse l'unica
normale tra tutte proprio cassetto unica
perfetto raga perfetto ma dov'è il
casinò make a face interni
certo ce l'ho fatta e la pro giusta come
era quello giusto fantastico andiamo
d'altra parte dalla moto perfetto la
merda e non dovete incarcerare di kaki
tuoi grazie ma salvato che mi ha salvato
ce l'ha fatta
grazie tesoro
l'esca bellissimo anche all'ultimo raga
ma anche all'ultimo ma posso andarmene
senza di lei ma chrome mi gonfio la
testa si sballa un sacco di così lo sai
se a me certo credo che la mia
insegnante di fisica avrebbe delle dei
ripensamenti si sta roba
ma andiamo comunque avanti ragazzi leaf
[Musica]
non voglio commentare niente di tutto
questo ma io per andrè con razzo scusate
c'è perché chi la usa la nave ai poveri
i poveri
che schifo i poveri ecco è fatto grande
sia il runner le scale quando c'è una
crisi con il motoscafo la chiamo la mia
famiglia goss in me l'hanno migliorato
molto anche questo è prevista invece i
ragazzi cosa mi piace anche invece
scelgono la descrizione lasciate un
commento qui sotto ragazzi perché voglio
sapere cosa ne pensate e noi come sempre
ci vediamo al prossimo video era ragazzi
[Musica]